so just stay to this side of it finding
out what life is like without vision
Microsoft have gathered the press to
show off the device they hope will
revolutionize the lives of the visually
impaired but first a train journey the
headset as I mentioned should fit just
in front of the year so it should be the
speaker should just be there on the
actual boat this allows the user to have
you know to be aware of the environment
around it around him while at the same
time a lot of the app to give
information to the user in a small city
just outside London Microsoft's lined a
track with beacons the headsets connect
with the beacons and tell users how
they're going to get to where they're
going and what's around them Microsoft
has tested the device on eight people
Gerald James is one of them you get lots
of information that you wouldn't
normally have walking around for
instance shops and different obstacles
which even though my guide dog is
trained to walk around them it's
additional information which is very
useful it also gives you information of
the shot different kinds of shots you're
passing and different things on the
shows when you actually go into a shop
two million people in the UK are
visually impaired and a hundred and
eighty thousand of them rarely or never
leave their homes reading station ticket
gate entrance this device is designed to
remove some of the anxiety about leaving
the house
Tesco first Great Western and others
have all signed up to use beacons these
are designed to help users navigate
inside establishments taking it
mainstream has its fair share of
challenges if we focus on the experience
and we enable people to enjoy those
capabilities the the actual technology
structure investments they will take
place because they have very broad
applications
field road turn left for bus stop there
are no plans for the device to be sold
just yet though until then helping the
visually impaired will still be the job
of a cane or man's best friend